the second topic turkey overall the
relations with turkey have improved
recently
there is a de-escalation in the eastern
mediterranean there
are talks between turkey and greece and
that's a good starting point
but on the other hand we still see
little if no
progress made on cyprus and this remains
disappointing first on trade turkey has
taken steps to address some
irritants like for example the
certificates of origin
and we encourage turkey to do more we
have already made clear that we will
continue
supporting turkey and other partners in
the region like
jordan or lebanon which hosts millions
of syrian refugees
therefore we always
show that we have supported in the past
and we plan
to support in the future we plan to
allocate an
additional 3 billion euro to support
refugees in turkey
until 2024 this money will come entirely
from the eu budget
and it will focus more on the social
economic
support to refugees at the same time
the commission will also provide 2.2
billion euro
until 2024 to support syrian refugees in
jordan
and in lebanon the third subject was
russia indeed we agreed on a united
long-term and strategic european
approach based on the report
that was presented last week as the
report
details out we are right now in a
negative spiral and we need to brace for
further downturn so we agreed to push
back
when russia targets the european union
and what we stand for when it
violates human rights to constrain
russia
when it attempts to undermine our
interests
and we will engage russia when it is in
our interest to do so to achieve our
goals
for example if we talk about climate
change
or if we talk about public health